hello there chapter 5 of fortnite took
us away from the hold of the zero point
and opened up the metaverse before our
lives are taken over by Lego racing and
Rhythm games let's take a look at some
of the map Secrets Easter eggs and
references to Old fortnite that can be
found on the current version of The
Island I would be honored if you'd use
my code this season I'm adamaru thanks
muchly let's do this first to the coral
buddies they have returned to the island
these random crust ations we've never
really understood but we've always tried
to help get your butt over to this spot
here and you'll find a cave Venture
through it grabbing the treasure on the
way and you'll hit a solid wall break it
and there's enough room to swim on you
have now arrived the new home of the
wobbly blobs they look to be starting a
new Colony here there's only a few right
now they look to have arrived by boat
too their gallion sits happily in the
water I'm very hopeful that this story
will grow but the last time they set up
home they soon soon cause nuclear
fallout more Coral buddies can also be
spotted on this island here singing
their iconic song this seems to be the
place of lots of things from fortnite's
history Captain CP signage there's old
Coliseum stuff and stolen artifacts from
KO Thorn shinanigans last season and
even the top half of the iconic tomato
head fresh from tomato Temple that's not
all as Coral Castle has a few trinkets
here and is this Sky notice board from
chapter 2 season 2 the iconic Midas
season you'll be surprised how many
references you'll find around the island
About That season also on this tiny
Island you can find brutus's helmet from
guess what chapter 2 season 2 and that
is the ball that meowzel liked so much
too I'm starting to think midas's loot
breaker protocol was successful after
all okay let's travel a little further
up the shoreline and you'll spot this
rig inside randomly on a chair is this
tntina's welding mask and you've guessed
it tantina is from chapter 2 season 2
this of course could simply be reused
assets but let's add one more part to
this Theory visit this solitary location
here and you'll find that someone is
collecting everything from the loop from
military grade equipment to
entertainment and what I found most
interesting is hidden behind this
partition this my friends is the
favorite chair of Midas the place where
he came up with the loop Breaker Program
all right I'll shut up about Midas let's
get back to map
changes the most bizarre update on the
map is found on the West Side an island
has naturally formed a love heart
doesn't it hit you right in the fields
this has also become the perfect
location for weddings to take place but
nobody expected this two petrified frogs
are becoming one they look very happy I
think if you get there in person rather
than replay files you'll see a bow too
these guys appeared one year ago on the
chapter 4 map and did absolutely nothing
all year this already is an improvement
so Peter Griffin is now in the game and
has his own POI not only that he has a
flag meaning this is an official
fortnite faction now anyway before you
start fighting the big man take a look
at his water feature because it's him
the lovely little cherub come get spat
on anytime you want I don't think I can
say that can I I think the only way to
describe this is the greatest Physique
in human history oky doie when fighting
Peter be sure to stick around after you
defeat him because this will
happen ah it's the random fall meme that
nobody can
forget you're doing an impression right
now I can
tell to the under ground we go deep
below the island is the new home of
Jonesy with his new blonde stubble his
makeshift home has a board of targets
for us to take out what I thought was a
great detail was
this the faces are crossed out as each
Target is defeated it's a minute little
detail but I respect it hugely GG devs
while here take a look at Jon's monitors
and you'll see three Silhouettes are
shown peely and Jones the two main parts
of this season's story as Jones tasks us
with saving his banana a friend but look
who is the third it's Sloan even though
the timeline is a bit messed up Jones
remembers his commanding officer and
continues to search for her I'm very
thankful the fortnite storyline hasn't
forgotten Sloan oh and speaking of peely
his locker icon has changed to a
Polaroid version of the yellow dude a
little reminder in our locker that this
season is about finding peely the
graffiti this season is amazing so many
references to so many seasons of
fortnite but one in Jones's headquarters
is totally new the TMNT it's finally
happening the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles are coming I can finally stop
using this cheap cosplay and in fact we
already know where they will be in a
future update this adjoining room here
will change to suit the turtles I'm
expecting pizza boxes everywhere I may
be the only one but I'm Legit very
excited for TMNT to come to fortnite
have you visited the new risky reels
ruined reels a Pantheon for
entertainment this season but it hasn't
forgotten to add advertise upcoming
movies I'm hoping this one comes true
revenge of the coral buddies as we know
they have arrived this could be
foreshadowing for their epic rise to
power another returning Easter egg do
you remember the iconic bear on a chair
we wasted many years watching this thing
as it hid in bushes or watched from
hilltops there was even a time where the
chair shrank so small only zooming in in
replay files could spot it well anyway
he's back again he sat on the viaduct
watching us all judging us
all when a new island arrives in
December we're never quite sure what
will happen to the snow after the
Christmas period well it looks like
we've got an answer already at each of
the train and bus stop locations are
these images and take a look at the snow
according to this the snow biome will be
much much smaller soon so enjoy it while
you can Rebels Roost lavish layer and
classy cot will be green in a future
update the amount of sports are is on
the island has grown dramatically this
season multiple tennis courts there's
even Beach football available and is
that a 10 Pin bowling lane all these
references were noticed in the live
event too as we explored the metaverse
multiple NBA teams were showcased it's
likely more game modes are coming as
fortnite evolves past Battle Royale and
fortnite indeed did intend to create a
playable basketball game years ago and
finally it looks like it's coming true
whilst in the event did you notice the
bright pink Fall Guy got his first
official reveal as an epic games game
let's see what Ninja thinks about that
Among Us yeah mate Among Us definitely
one last cool detail in the event did
you see the rock face in the racing mode
as we cross the line it was the shape of
a llama amazing touch anyway back to BR
Island the last place we need to visit
is the yacht the return of the marold
once home to Midas and once home to
Deadpool the new bad guys of the chapter
have a solid gold icon in the center of
the ship and here's what I'm thinking as
we look at this does this look like two
Golden Hands and an allseeing eye if
fortnite's story is to continue I think
this must be the return of Midas back
when he had his own live event about
57,000 years ago Midas attempted to
break the loop he seemed to fail but
maybe he didn't after all and this has
been his new home ever since that would
explain the countless chapter 2 season 2
references strew everywhere this season
Midas got out I'm Adam you're awesome
I'll see you next time